hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing fmr
daruda ah daruda
with black and he is playing really
quickly
out of this nimzo larsen
opening
i don't know not an expert here g6 maybe
[Music]
um it's kind of a reversed hedgehog yeah
what what it's doing if i would go
d5 which i don't okay
yeah this is a very solid setup for
white
six
okay
okay where do we put the pieces 95
i can always take
queen is usually good on b7 in such a
position
and then maybe later go for a6b5
things
things great english ideas
yeah looks kind of normal
okay
pawn takes i guess okay i have this one
which is
important i feel
for a tempo on the pawn
okay i'm i think fast enough there on
that file
now um rook
c4 maybe
trying to fight for the c
file yes it's playable
it's still nothing special
or so but i can try at least to fight
for the c file
okay covers that pawn so
i can try b5 here
or queen to c7 yeah queen c7
keeps yeah i keep the c file here
so i managed to press a little bit of
water out of stone here already
the position was essentially dead and
now
i have a little something so
queen d4 is not a threat actually so
i don't have to play f6 i mean f6 is
often helpful to not have to worry to
that you don't have to worry about the
checks what i'm trying to say
unsuccessfully but
sometimes this can be an option okay
do we trade queens here i think it can
go here right
g4 makes no sense
it still makes no sense um
queen c3 or i mean a rook ending is very
very little but
i also have this idea so if he
tries to avoid the queen trade i have
this check
i think in many cases which can be
annoying
and i'm also on the pawn so kind of
difficult for him to not trade
okay so
he's attacking this pawn
rook c7 or what's going on rook c7
[Music]
if i take b4 he takes a7
i don't see a good continuation then
actually
so let's cover the pawn
that's a very strange move why would he
put this rook exactly there
so
looks vulnerable okay
i'm angling for this
maybe also rook c for some time if he
takes
i take with a pawn i have a c pawn
it could be dangerous i have to watch
out for the time
while trying to press water out of stone
i
i spent some time
not so easy for whitehead to make a move
i mean he always has to watch out for
that rook now
okay
i also have rook f1 in this position
[Music]
and i have the check and this is this is
annoying
queen d4 drops the f4 pawn
queen g3 is made in one
okay so check
queen c3 is that saving him yes ah
shoot
that's a real pain
a real pain
maybe he had e5 there
[Music]
okay in terms of
time the worst is over but it's it's
probably just equal now
oh that's a pain i should have won that
game of course
he did everything in his power to lose
it and i did not win it
so yeah
i think this is pretty much equal and
then he like
systematically killed himself
like giving me the c file weakening and
so on like
this was a suicide suicide mission
more or less but i could not win it
so this one
book d4 and anyway so so rook c4 an idea
that i
mentioned was good but this this should
win right
so this and this and how do we win now
check and now queen g1 wins yeah for
queen h2 and what not
i i the queen c3 for christ's sake
that's the only move that saves them
i saw that too late
i saw that too late queen g1 is is just
over
[Music]
i mean he just weakened himself the
whole time
and um this is a draw right
that's a draw
yeah that's just nothing
and it's a bit disappointing because the
thing is
like if it does nothing like nothing
like here you just have to make a
reasonable move like take here
and and play this position it's a little
bit
better for black but it's just nothing
special
but like b form why give up that square
why weaken the king and so on and so on
it was like a
you just systematically made his
position worse so that's annoying that i
couldn't exploit it
i mean i could indeed for a long while
but
queen f6 is just not cutting it
it's one of those cases where
when i would have played f6 at some
point it wouldn't have happened
anyway thanks for watching